First we calculate the slope of
our line using the slope function.
In this case the slope is 0.1817.
Meaning that for
each additional employee at a client we
will receive 0.1817 additional tickets.
Second, we calculate the y-intercept
point, using the intercept function.
Giving us a value of -7.546.
And lastly, we calculate
the coefficient of determination or
r-squared using the RSQ function.
Resulting in an r-squared
value of 0.7862.
In addition, let's quickly generate
a scatter plot with a trend line and
r-squared.
Using Google Sheets we
calculated the linear
equation to be y = 0.1817x - 7.546,
with an r-squared value of 0.7862.
For a new client with 525 employees,
we could expect
0.1817 x 525 - 7.546, or 87.86 tickets per week.
Which is approximates to
around 88 tickets per week.
The r-squared value is not as
good as in the prior example, and
you can see by looking at the plot that
the points are a bit more scattered.